We've done lots of experiments with the alkaline metals,
pop it into the water and see what we can do with the reaction.
You can see the orange sodium flame,
but our technician Neil felt that we weren't really doing them
scientifically enough.
We were just dropping alkaline metals into water and seeing what happened.
And we've also done the reverse experiment,
water falling onto sodium.
But what Neil felt is we should do something that was much more controlled.
He wanted to break ampoules glass vessels containing the
alkaline metals underwater.
So we can watch the reaction before there is any air present.
[Inaudible].
And also he had the second idea that we should compare the
same number of atoms of the three metals.
The teacher shows sodium potassium and Caesium,
but today I'm going to show you the first experiment,
which was with sodium Neil's device,
begins with a plastic box,
which is filled with water with flat sides.
So you can video and you can see both under the water and what's happening on
the surface. Inside is a device,
which he hasn't made the name yet. I sort of like a thumb screw,
but for test tubes where by turning a soft,
which goes a long way away from the trough,
he can force a metal pin into the side of a test tube
so that it breaks.
And you can film the whole thing at different speeds and from different angles.
[Inaudible].
When the tube breaks water rushes in and the reaction starts.
And the only way that the metal can become in contact with air is if
it floats up to the surface
And a cesium tube, it was evacuated without any air.
In some of the other tubes that was air,
you will see in one of our videos, the tube wasn't quite properly sealed.
So it was full of air,
but the amount of air in the tube is very small compared to the amount of
hydrogen that you expect to be generated by full reaction,
the experiments were done outside so that we had bright
sunlight. And also, so if there was an explosion,
it wouldn't cause any harm in the building.
What see is that as the pin starts breaking and the bubbles
are coming out, I believe our hydrogen and the hydrogen,
just bubbles up to the surface when it gets to the surface,
there is some cloudiness,
which I think is probably just an optical illusion from the sun.
There may be some mist of water inside it because from sunbank angles,
they look transparent. On the other hand, Neil and Bray,
do you think it might be something we're interesting and I'm prepared to be
corrected. If we do more experiments, once the reaction gets going,
you get more and more bubbles.
But to begin with there isn't much evidence of any fire
or anything burning the hydrogen just dissipates.
And then gradually the reaction goes more rapidly.
At the end. There is a huge Bush,
which in our first video,
which is about sodium effectively wipes everything out on the screen,
partly because I think heat,
which is generated by these reactions is registered
on video screens as just white light.
What I think happens at the end is that sodium,
which has a density that is quite similar to water is carried up by the
hydrogen bubbles.
And it all reacts on the surface and with the air and explodes,
there are a number of questions that will strike you immediately.
The first thing is it all looks very rapid,
but from the point of view of a chemist, it's really pretty slow.
It took a good fraction of a second,
really fast chemical reactions take place in a nanosecond,
a thousand millionth of a second.
And here we're talking 0.1 of the second something that's quite
slow. So this reaction is fast,
but it is slow enough for mechanical things like breaking of glass
and so on to take place.
What of course we haven't done is we haven't analyzed the bubbles and shown that
they are hydrogen.
But part of the reason for this is that the reaction of alkaline
metals and water is a very well researched area.
And I've got here a PhD thesis,
reactions of the liquid alkaline metals with water,
which was published in 1976.
This is not cutting edge research. Of course,
we now have high-speed cameras so that we can show you videos nice and
easily. But when these guys were researching,
they had high speed signal cameras. Unfortunately we've lost the film,
but we do have some nice photos.
So what we take with this is that a lot of this is already known.
The reason why this research was being was because in the
1970s,
people were building nuclear reactors with hundreds of
tons of liquid sodium in them,
which also had water cooling and people wanted to know what would
happen if the sodium leaked into the water system.
So I have an 80 year old colleague now retired,
who supervised this research.
He looks at all our videos with some amusement and says,
when will the young generation ever learn?
His point of view is that you could save a lot of research
time by reading the old papers. In fact,
there is a cliche that you can save six months in the lamp
with two hours in the library.
So you've seen sodium well
clearly waiting like me to see potassium and Caesium,
but those will be the next speakers.